quattro will be our indian starting
pitcher and he has been on a roll folks
he's been pitching very well
in his last six starts he's three and oh
150 era ahmed rosario fields a ground
ball
marcana is retired one down
[Applause]
shatters a battle like we're seeing
there
two down
in the air left field routine
harold
cal cuatro glides through the first
frankie montos making his 23rd start
this season and frankie montage has just
become a heavyweight knockout artist 40
punch-outs over the last 30 and a third
innings
lined in the left field a base hit for
bradley zimmer that ball got on markana
in a hurry
there he goes
swinging a miss throw down
and on his way to third ted barrett
looking to john gomes who wanted
interference and ted barrett's going to
send him back he is he's going to send
him i i think there was interference
we'll see if rosario came over the plate
oh the bat hit him and then he comes up
over the plate he says he moved in to my
throwing space they're gonna send zimmer
all the way back to first base
so one down and jose ramirez coming up
and he missed outside ball four so
montas like so many working around jose
ramirez even in the first inning
and a little one hopper and this is
trouble it's a
would have been a double play but only
he's gonna score and the indians will
get a run bradley zimmer yeah
automatic double play ball but the throw
short hopped olson he couldn't pick it
and my goodness they're gonna get one on
the board here you go you had to
hesitate but by the time lowry gets his
ball
and he short hops olsen and he couldn't
pick it and that's one of the best in
the business over there boy the indians
lucky they get a run take a one-nothing
lead and big herald to the plate
smashed up the middle and through big
harold does it again
second straight night he's got a two out
rbi single in the first this one extends
the indians lead to two to nothing
yeah you want to talk about a terrific
at bat
that's what falling off some two strike
pitches will do he ended up he didn't
want to walk him he comes at him with a
pretty good fastball but he's ready this
one right down the middle a good at-bat
by harold there goes big harold
gomes throw is in time and it's a good
one uh-oh
that's not good well big harrell
delivering the two-out rbi single but
he will not stay in the game he felt
something cramped you see he just pulls
up
and slows down and that's hard to do
when you're running full speed you know
but he felt something i don't know where
it was uh just didn't feel comfortable
to the top of the second and cleave on
the israel two nothing and a line drive
and a leaping grab it's short by ahmed
rosario
one away rosario had it timed
beautifully
he's going to jump up and make the catch
and i mean there wasn't a whole lot of
time
to decide you time it you get it up
and you catch it
on a no two pitch so that's a good play
good out
swinging a miss hey struck him out first
k for quantrill two down here in the
second inning
oh my goodness oh hello
wow
what an advent and quantrill finally
gets the strikeout
we go to the third austin hitch is the
number nine hitter to face frankie
montas here's the one-two fastball swing
and a miss some high octane at 97
and blows hedges away there's one out
and that is the second strikeout tonight
for motos
and strike three called on the outside
corner so back-to-back strikeouts for
frankie montana
a good breaking ball maybe the best
slider of the night for frankie montos
he strikes out the side two nothing
indians on top as we go to the fifth
inning
a three pitch strikeout for cal cuatro
give him four k's on the night yeah nice
nice sequence there
swinging
hey struck him out on three pitches back
to back k's to end the fifth the indians
lead to nothing lowry leads off in the
seventh
and jed's able to lay off and the ace
for the second inning in a row get a
lead off walk 0-2 pitch swung on line
toward right that's going to drop for a
hit around second racing a third is jed
lowry he will get there without a throw
and the a's are
in business with runners at the corners
gomes on an o2 pitch
shoots one in the right center field two
on and nobody out and brian shaw is up
and loosening in a hurry in the
cleveland bullpen 14 consecutive
scoreless innings for cal cuatro but
he'll leave
with two on
nobody out brian shaw worked a scoreless
inning last night he'll have mitch
moreland at the plate
rosario the only out is going to be at
first base so the run will come in to
score that's lowry it's two to one and
the runner goes to second base so really
a very very productive out for moreland
up the middle center field of ace hit
here comes john gomes he's being waved
home there will not be a throw and the
a's have tied it here in the seventh so
chapman got it through
for the rbi hit it just felt like this
at bat was going to set up play into the
hands of matt chapman i said brian shaw
likes that heater away well he got one
and you can see shaw almost pull the
glove back
worried about clipping the baseball
slowing it down thinking he's got
defenders behind him unfortunately not
the case
got him looking bring him up two down
runner goes throw down by hedges it's in
time and oh got him in the inning
what a great throw
chapman trying to swipe the bag and get
in the scoring position with two outs
but hedges
with a perfect throw ends the inning
jake dietman takes over for frankie
montas 2-2 with a 3.07 era for jake
diekmann his 46th appearance
and he draws the two out walk like it so
you get the speedster aboard oscar
mercado they hit her
there's a ball hit well
midfield on the run cannon can't get it
it's over his head
straw flying around third
throw to the plate forget about it
the indians take the lead
boy how about that
that
couldn't have been any better timing
for oscar mercado he just drilled that
ball into the gap cannon wasn't going to
get there i thought he might catch up to
it it was hit too hard we go to the
eighth inning demarlo hale turns the
game over now to nick samlin the 2-1
pitch elvis it's a high fly ball to left
and back on it mercado is deep at the
track right to the wall and gone
alva sandra's hits it out to left field
in cleveland in the eighth inning this
ball game is tied a's three indians
three he gets it up and over the 19 foot
high wall in left and it's 3-3 in the
eighth
swung on fouled it upstairs boy he had a
good cut and sandlin bent over at the
waist hopefully nothing's wrong i wonder
if something's wrong with sandlin he's
walking off the mound and something
doesn't look right
he didn't like the way something felt
and i don't think he's gonna be able to
continue because he's not even
going anywhere near the pitcher's mouth
trevor stefan coming into a tough
situation it's a tie game and there are
two men on base nobody out and he's got
the big dog jed lowry here's the 2-1 to
lowry swung on hit to right field hit
deep way back zimmer at the track he'll
turn and watch it fly a tremendous shot
to right field by lowry and these have
turned this game around it's 6-3
athletics in the top of the 8th
jed lowry deep in the lower deck and
right field at progressive field and
it's a four run eighth for the a's and
lowry's 13th home run and he scores
kiana and marseille ahead of him so lou
trevino comes in he's gonna be looking
for his 19th save of the year high
pop-up on the infield and this should do
it tony kemp grabs it and that is indeed
the ball game so the a's do late inning
magic again
and they are now a season high 18 games
over the 500 mark
you